ce sont les nouveaux occupants de la
villa d'aimé césaire l'une est
ethnologue les autres sont archiviste
depuis mars il y passe quelques heures
par jour leur tâche est à la fois
passionnante complexe est fort utile
mireille mon désir à la responsabilité
du mobilier
ce meuble par exemple rappelle le liens
qu'entretenait aimé césaire et georges
braque les initiateurs de l'art
contemporain la halle enquête que je
m'aime cela me montre qu'il s'agit d'un
meuble qui a été spécialement conçu par
les ateliers municipaux de la ville de
fort de france pour recevoir les
feuillets et carnets du feuillet des
dessins de brac
donc là on a quelque chose de très
intéressant parce qu'il n'y en a pas
deux il est unique
il s'agit de raconter le lien entre
l'objet et son propriétaire un travail
de fourmi qui identifie tout ce que
contient la maison de l'écrivain
mesurait hauteur/largeur définir le type
de matériau faire une description la
plus exhaustive possible mettre en avant
des signes particuliers intéressant pour
une éventuelle conservation ou
restauration et faire ressentir
l'histoire associé à se mobilier la
villa d'aimé césaire est à l'image de
son propriétaire
humble et accessible il n'était pas du
tout dans une surenchère de possessions
matérielles mais plutôt bien dans la
surenchère de possession intellectuelle
c'est archiviste ont pour leur part la
responsabilité de répertorier la
bibliothèque d'aimé césaire à ce jour
l'estimation serait d'environ 3000
ouvrages il y a le catalogage classique
mais pas seulement
il faut qu'on fasse attention par
exemple une dédicace
une mention une annotation l'état du
livre la convenance du livre l'éditeur
des fois
cet inventaire est indispensable pour
identifier valoriser et protéger un
patrimoine la maison d'aimé césaire est
classé monument historique
à l'issue de ce long travail il s'agira
d'aller encore plus loin
yann scénographie qui devait être mise
en place car cela qu'un en train de
travailler justement avec l'architecte
du patrimoine qui est dans quelle équipe
été choisie est sélectionné pour tout
une cellule qui travaillent dessus pour
que tout soit en lien en même temps et
surtout respecte et continue en
extension à penser les mais césaire
donc c'est ça aussi c'est donner le
passé le présent le futur qu'on puisse
joindre tout ça le projet de
restauration et de réhabilitation de
cette maison commencera au plus tôt en
fin d'année pour une ouverture d'ici